welcome to the heavy spoilers show
i'm your host paul aka the best of a bad
bunch
in this video we're breaking down
episode four of the bad batch
so far the series set in a galaxy far
far away has had a lot of easter eggs
hidden details
and things in it that have made it a joy
to recap and explain
in this video we're gonna be going over
the latest entry and discussing what we
think could be happening next time
episode three saw the bad batch doing a
mandalorian season 2
and crash landing on a moon as they made
their way to ida floor
omega was finally embraced by the group
and she ended up filling the void left
by crosshair after proving that she had
the metal to make her way through the
kind of missions that they would be
going on
rekka ended up making a room for her out
of what i believe was crosshair's old
one
and he himself realized that he was
probably heading down the wrong path
when we watched as the empire brought in
the elite troopers
as we know civilians and mercs would go
on to replace the clones
and he was simply helping to usher in a
new era
so far the show is very much tackled
with the aesthetic of conformity versus
independence
and we watched as the bad batch travel
on highly different paths to crosshair
they've even repeated scenes with
different outcomes to show this motif
and you know it's like poetry they rhyme
i also forgot to mention last time that
tolkien has now been promoted to
imperial governor
from republic admiral further showing
how things are changing
we pick up with clone force 99 drifting
through space
towards the moon either floor the last
two episodes had them first showing up
in hyperspace
but here they're gliding through which
hints towards how badly beaten up the
ship
is the episode titled cornered has has
them
well cornered at several points i like
this nice slow
and cold opening i'd never heard of
idaflow before
and after researching the planet i
couldn't find any instances of it
mentioned
however if you know a book film gamer
show that it's been in
then let me know but it does seem like a
new creation for this episode
the uninhabited planet is the perfect
place for them to lay low
as because of its low population the
empire haven't sent anyone to oversee it
though the imperials have a vast martyr
of ships and soldiers
they don't have the manpower to cover
every single system in the galaxy
and planets without big populations are
overlooked
this allowed the jedi like yoda to hide
out on places like dagobah
and it's smart that the bad batch are
seeking out planets like this
however they need supplies and to modify
the ship so that they can scramble its
signal to go
undetected this sends them to pantora
which is a moon in the pantora system
located on the outer rim in star wars
law
pantora was blockaded by the trade
federation and ahsoka tano was sent in
to stop the takeover
pantora also held a place in the
galactic senate and is pretty much a
market world that has similar setups to
mos
eisley the batch land in the hangar bay
which is operated by an uggnut
who you might recognize as being the
same species as queel from the
mandalorian
after taking some money to keep quiet he
betrays them and messages fenik shand
who you will also probably recognize
from that show this series takes place
before she ever came face to face with
mando
and we discover that omega has a bounty
on her head
we've long been theorizing that omega is
actually a force sensitive clone
which the kaminowin started working on
in order to have more product lines
after the war ended
she is called omega which typically
means the end
and creating a force-sensitive clone
would of course be the final stage of
their development
whilst the war was going on the
kaminoans were dealing with the jedi
so it makes sense that they would want
to offer them something beyond the
typical grunt
that could easily fit into their ranks
and help win the war
i believe that they were working on
giving her the ability to wield the
force when everything went to hell
and are now trying to retrieve her in
order to stay relevant
pantora is filled with all types of
creatures including loth cats who of
course
showed up in the clone wars at several
points they were also in the mandalorian
too
so again it's like poetry they rhyme now
i love hunter's design here and they'll
be insane for weeks i think he's based
on rambo
i also think it might be a nod to billy
from predator
they enter the market to see the clones
being cheered on after ending the war
and rampart's chain code hologram is
playing which we saw
pop up in episode two zozo several sweep
bikes
and we can also see a clone trooper
action figure which is similar to the
stormtrooper doll that jin erso was
playing with at the start of rogue one
omega draws some attention i think that
the batch might have to decide whether
they want to protect it and live with
constantly being hunted
or have a free life after handing her
over obviously
it will go the former with this being
the kind of show that it is
but she's very much the person i think
that will make them become parents
this could lead to them putting their
lives on the line to protect her
and we know from an article posted by
screen rant this week that the ending of
the show is so
sad it made the composers cry so lots of
sad sad things to look forward to
on a friday and because of this i am
expecting some deaths
now speaking of fridays if you want to
give me that friday feeling
then please click the thumbs up button
it's the free way to help out the
channel
and it means that i don't have to get a
job and can do more videos like this
so cheers i guess wait wait that's a
that's a thumbs down yeah
shame on you now anyway omega finds
herself alone in the market
where she's approached by fennec who
similar to the mandalorian
is voiced by ming na win echo is sold as
a droid because of his tech parts
and at the back of the store he comes
across a protocol droid
similar to c3po see kids that's that's
why you come here
you never never would have known that on
your own now echo removes their
restraining bolts
which you may remember appeared in a new
hope luke removed r2d2s
and he went off to look for obi-wan on
his own and yes
it's like poetry they rhyme bennig talks
about being a merc
and how it's okay to break the rules
sometimes and as we know this idea of
rule breaking would massively play into
her character later on
as she worked from off gideon for some
time before leaving his imperial squad
to go on the run
she teamed up with boba fett and was
paramount in gideon's downfall
so i love how there's this foreshadowing
here under catch is up to her but she
manages to best him
however the authorities show up in order
to arrest her
she is and always has been somewhat of
an outlaw
and is slowly becoming one of my
favorite characters after the disney
star wars takeover
things are starting to heat up and tech
tracks omega to a maintenance tunnel
whereka finds her but she's being
tracked by fenik who uses his weight
against him omega ends up climbing up a
maintenance tower
and at the top she's cornered after
bringing the droids to the hangar they
start to fix up the ship
and we hear that one of them is called
clink this is actually a nickname of an
r2 astromech droid
who was given to mindonos when he was in
raid's squadron
probably not one in the same but
potentially this is a little nod to
their character from the expanded lore
omega is knocked off the edge but she's
saved by fennick
showing that she's not all bad hunter
grabs a swoop bike and follows them
through the air after shan drops her on
a carrier
and it leads to a chase that reminded me
a lot of the one from the first act of
attack of the clones
hunter is knocked off course and shan
ends up killing some of the police
in a moment that i really wasn't
expecting to see
see kids this show isn't for kids now
get the hell out of here
now hunter throws a magnetic mind to
shan's ride and he's blown out of the
sky
but we know from the trailer shots that
she will be back my guess is that she's
gonna wait until they return to this
planet
and though i don't think she will pop up
in the next century i think it'll be
sooner rather than later she might even
end up getting employed by tarkin or
rampart
who are of course looking for elite
soldiers this would give her a gateway
to go on to meet gideon
and there are a lot of potential routes
that the show can take
she goes back to her contact and pays
for him to keep an eye out for the group
and though i don't think that he'll ever
pop up in the series again
i think this is more kind of showing
that she's looking for them throughout
the galaxy
the group deduced that omega is a wanted
bounty and they decide to find out who's
put the target on her head
i think that this is the cameron owens
as all of shan's actions indicated that
she wanted the child alive
which they of course would too they did
want to keep her safe at the end of
episode 1
so that just makes the most sense to me
however it could be someone like captain
rex who may have learned of her
importance and he may now want to keep
her out of harm's way
i'd obviously love to hear your theories
below and it seems that she's far more
important than the rest of the group is
as there are no bounties on their heads
let me know who you think is after her
and if you're right i can pass it off as
my own theory
and take all the credit thanks now as
for the series so far
i feel like the episodes are slightly
understated in terms of the
over-the-top action and balls to the
wall well balls
however i am quite enjoying this more
subtext-laced take
which centers more on the journey and
politics of the galaxy
rather than just non-stop shooting
that's not to say the action scenes
aren't big and bad
but they do have more meaning behind
them than your typical run and gun
firing on all cylinders type scenes
whether it's crosshair gunning down one
of the soldiers he's been told to train
or omega crawling through a cave every
action scene feels like it has character
development in it
now that's kind of an old point to talk
about but it's just something i've not
mentioned so far
that i think is definitely worth
applauding the show for again this was
another super solid episode that i
really enjoyed
and though these entries are short and
sweet we're getting some of the best
character development that has been in a
star wars property for a long time
another bad batch are often regarded as
just things like
the grunt skin the heavy skin and so on
but the show has done a great job of
allowing us to actually get to know how
they think
and feel they're of course having to
deal with the fact that they're now
outlaws
and it's a really gripping watch so far
these four episodes have been a blast
and i can't wait to see what happens at
the halfway point of the series
now obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts on the show so make sure you
comment below and let me know
as a thank you for interacting with the
video you'll be entered into a prize
through on the 30th of may
in which we're giving away three copies
of the godzilla versus con collection
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications
on and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the episode
the winners of last month's competition
are on screen right now
so that's you then message me on twitter
heavy spoilers if you want something
else to watch
make sure you check out our breakdown of
why omniman might have been right
which will be linked on screen right now
we've talked about the pros and cons of
ultramite invasion and it's definitely
worth watching if you want a little fun
video
and without all the way thank you for
singing through this one i've been paul
i hope you have a great weekend take
care yourself peace